Profª. Tamar Gendler: Então, nós
terminamos a última aula
numa situação um pouco desconcertante.
Refletimos sobre os
cenários particulares
apresentados por Judy Thomson no
seu artigo do Trolley.
E descobrimos uma característica
aparentemente desconcertante
nas respostas da classe.
No chamado caso da Testemunha Clássica,
em que há uma testemunha
ao lado de um trem
que segue desgovernado pelos trilhos,
prestes a atingir 5 pessoas,
e a testemunha pode desviar
o trem para uma via
onde ele se chocará a 1 pessoa...
As respostas dadas foram as seguintes:
Cerca de 15% acharam que ela
estava moralmente obrigada
a desviar o trem, dos 5 para 1.
70% de vocês acharam que ela estava
moralmente permitida a fazer isso.
E apenas 15% acharam que é um
ato moralmente proibido
ela desviar o trem dos 5 para 1.
Por outro lado, acabamos a classe
com o famoso caso do Homem
Gordo, de Thomson.
É um caso em que a nossa testemunha
está de pé ao lado do trem,
como antes, o trem segue desgovernado
pelos trilhos, prestes a matar 5,
e a testemunha tem à sua
disposição um meio para parar o
trem.
Nesse caso, em vez de mudar a via,
o meio que ela tem à disposição
é empurrar um homem gordo
de uma ponte, interrompendo,
assim, a trajetória do trem.
E as suas respostas nesse caso
exibiram uma distribuição muito
diferente da do 1º caso.
Enquanto que, no 1º caso,
15% de vocês acharam
que era proibido impedir o
trem de atingir 5,
matando 1 ou fazendo com que
o trem matasse 1,
no caso do homem gordo, 78% de
vocês – 4/5 da turma –
acharam que o ato de
desviar ou parar o trem,
colocando na sua trajetória uma outra
pessoa, era moralmente proibido.
Agora o quebra-cabeça que isso sugere,
como vocês sabem pela última aula,
é que parece que tanto no
caso da testemunha...
Desculpem. O quebra-cabeça é
este: No caso da testemunha,
parece claro para a maioria das
pessoas que matar 1 pessoa é ruim,
mas que deixar 5 morrerem é pior.
Ao passo que, no caso do homem gordo,
parece ser justamente o inverso.
Então, o que Thomson
questiona no final do texto,
depois de percorrer uma série de casos,
incluindo alguns que eu não abordei
neste resumo, é o seguinte:
o que poderia explicar a
diferença nas nossas reações
no caso da testemunha e no
do homem gordo?
E o que ela sugere é que,
enquanto a utilidade proíbe deixar 5
pessoas morrerem – ou seja,
eria melhor para o número de vidas
conservadas salvar 5 que salvar 1 –,
a noção de direitos
proíbe matar 1 pessoa
no caso do homem gordo.
Então, o que acontece no
caso do homem gordo,
diz Thomson, é que você
interfere com o direito de não
ter essa pessoa usada como um meio para
a finalidade de salvar outra.
Ao passo que, no caso da testemunha,
não há direito a ser infringido.
E Thomson sugere: "os direitos
triunfem sobre a utilidade".
Então, o direito proíbe
o que é compulsório no
caso do homem gordo.
Então aqui é onde estávamos no
final da última aula.
E a solução proposta por Thomson
é o que poderíamos chamar
de uma solução clássica para os
dilemas do tipo Trolley.
É uma solução que supõe que
o caso do homem gordo
e o da testemunha possuem
diferentes mandatos morais
e que eles possuem esses
diferentes mandatos por causa
de uma diferença moral profunda,
que esses casos codificam.
A diferença entre a nossa
resposta para o homem gordo
e a nossa resposta para a testemunha,
diz Thomson neste artigo de 1985,
é algo que deve ser respeitado.
E a razão pela qual devemos respeitar
essa diferença, ela afirma,
é que ela está marcando uma
diferença moral profunda entre ambos,
ou seja, que no caso do homem gordo,
mas não no caso da testemunha,
os direitos de um
indivíduo são violados.
Na aula de hoje, eu quero
analisar com vocês
3 respostas não-clássicas
para o caso do Trolley.
E vocês terão a oportunidade
de usar os seus clickers
no 1º e no 3º caso.
Se vocês já forem pegando os clickers,
estaremos prontos para o que vai
ocorrer daqui a pouco.
Então, quais são as 3
respostas não-clássicas?
Lembrem-se, numa resposta clássica,
a alegação é que o homem
gordo e a testemunha
possuem diferentes mandatos
morais e que essa diferença
pode ser atribuída a uma mais profunda:
a diferença moralmente
relevante entre eles.
Portanto, as 2 respostas que
vamos considerar hoje
são aquelas que sugerem que o
homem gordo e a testemunha,
na verdade, não possuem
diferentes mandatos morais.
O 1º exemplo analisado repensa
os casos do Trolley num artigo
de Judy Thomson de 2008,
em que ela acaba igualando o
caso da testemunha
e o caso do homem gordo.
Ela sugere que em nenhum dos
casos é permitido
matar 1 para salvar 5.
A 2ª opinião que vamos
considerar é a de Josh Greene,
de que a coisa certa a se fazer
no caso do homem gordo é a mesma
no caso da testemunha,
ou seja, em ambos os casos a coisa
certa a se fazer é impedir
que o trem atinja 5 e
fazer com que mate 1.
E, finalmente... Estou forçando um
pouco a barra, porque, na verdade,
Sunstein está um pouco mais
próximo de Greene que de Thomson.
Mas podemos usar o pensamento dele
para manter a posição de que,
embora existe diferença entre
as nossas respostas,
os casos têm o mesmo
sentido fundamental.
E Sunstein sugere
que o que precisamos fazer é
empurrar o homem gordo.
Portanto, temos aqui os 3
pontos de vista.
Thomson dizendo que os casos vêm
juntos e eles nos dizem
para nunca matar 1 a fim de salvar 5.
Greene dizendo que os casos vêm
juntos e eles nos dizem
para sempre matar 1 a fim de salvar 5.
E, então, a visão de Sunstein talvez
nos esteja dizendo que os
casos vêm à parte.
Mas essas 3 respostas
não-clássicas são
interessantes
não apenas pela
diferença de conteúdo;
elas são interessantes para os
objetivos desta aula
porque cada uma delas utiliza um
tipo ligeiramente diferente
de metodologia argumentativa.
E não há nenhuma razão para que as
metodologias e as respostas
se alinhem da forma que fizeram eles.
Uma das coisas que eu quero
que vocês reflitam
à medida que avançamos hoje
é sobre o uso que pode ser dado a
cada uma dessas metodologias
para criar um argumento alternativo.
Assim, a proposição de Thomson
de que no caso da testemunha não
devemos desviar o trem
está feita com o intuito
de convidá-los
– tal qual eu vou fazer
daqui a pouco –
a considerar hipóteses adicionais e,
em seguida, pedir que vocês sejam
consistentes nas respostas
aos casos que não diferem
nos aspectos morais.
A metodologia de Thomson
é a mesma da do seu artigo de 1985,
trata-se apenas de um novo
caso pensado por ela.
A metodologia de Sunstein
está baseada numa grande
variedade de literatura
na tradição das heurísticas e vieses
e sugere que o raciocínio moral
não é diferente de qualquer
outro tipo de raciocínio.
E o método de Josh Greene é,
naturalmente, utilizar os resultados
da neuroimagem e, desse modo,
argumentar a favor da sua perspectiva de
que o moralmente compulsório
de nós é um certo tipo de
postura utilitária.
Vamos começar – e vocês vão
precisar dos clickers –
com os casos hipotéticos adicionais
que convenceram Judy Thomson,
e pode convencê-los,
que não está bem desviar o
trem na testemunha.
O caso exposto por Thomson é um caso
que chamaremos de 3
Opções da Testemunha.
Aqui está o pobre Jim,
lamentando profundamente por
estar metido nesta aula,
perto do trem num dilema
habitual da testemunha,
em que o trem está prestes
a atingir 5 pessoas
e Jim tem a possibilidade de
desviá-lo para atingir 1.
Mas porque Jim vive a sua vida
no experimento pensado
por Judy Thomson, ela introduziu,
de forma bastante covarde,
uma 3ª via, infelizmente para Jim,
justo onde ele está parado.
Pois aqui está o dilema das 3 vias.
1: Deixar o trem continuar pelo
seu caminho original
e matar 5.
2: Desviar o trem para que
ele atinja 1 pessoa.
3: desviar o trem dos 5 para 1...
Oh, exceto que este 1 é Jim.
Questão. Na testemunha das 3 vias,
se Jim decide desviar o trem
– portanto estamos ignorando o fato
de ele deixar atingir os 5 –,
ele tomou a decisão de desviar o
trem, a questão é esta:
É moralmente obrigatório
para ele desviar o trem
para a via onde atinge o outro
cara em vez de dele mesmo?
É moralmente permitido, mas não
moralmente obrigatório,
para ele desviar o trem para a via
onde atinge o outro cara
em vez dele mesmo?
Ou é moralmente proibido para ele
desviar o trem para outra via,
e não para ele mesmo?
Estamos assumindo que Jim
tomou a decisão
de desviar o trem das 5 pessoas.
Afinal de contas, isso é um
caso direto da testemunha.
Se ele não desviar o
trem, vai atingir 5.
78% de vocês já me disseram
que o que se deve fazer,
ou pelo menos o que é permitido fazer
nesse caso, é desviar o trem.
Por que ainda não temos
nenhuma resposta, pessoal?
Estudantes: [vozes sobrepostas]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Não está
funcionando? Oh, meu Deus.
Tudo bem. Por que não está
aberta para vocês?
Vamos tentar.
Está aberta agora?
Estudante: Não.
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Que tragédia.
Isto é muito, muito, muito horrível.
Isso não funcionou.
Toda a aula de hoje depende
de que isso funcione.
Bom, vamos tentar de novo.
Digam-me se já funciona agora.
Está funcionando?
OK.
Está funcionando agora?
Não? Ainda não? Não?
Tudo bem. Mm. Vamos ter de continuar...
Eu acho que não há nada
que eu possa fazer.
Vou tentar reiniciar mais 1
vez e ver se dá certo.
Vou tentar remover e, depois, voltar
a encaixar este receptor.
E então... se não... vamos ter
de fazer à moda antiga,
levantando as mãos, e todos os meus
slides muito bem construídos
serão inúteis, mas tudo bem.
Coisas piores aconteceram no mundo.
Tudo bem. Tentem novamente.
Yay! Maravilha.
Eu não tenho ideia do que eu mudei.
OK. Então, respondendo a esta pergunta.
Uau. Há 64 de vocês.
Há 71 de vocês.
Vamos fazer a contagem regressiva.
10, 9, 8... e vamos ver os
números que saem...
4, 3, 2, 1 segundo. Ah, isso
é tão emocionante!
Especialmente porque tivemos
de sofrer primeiro.
O contraste.
OK. Então,
6% acham que é moralmente obrigatório
para Jim desviar o trem
para o outro homem.
Mas vocês são os 6% que
continuam discrepando...
ou talvez sejam pessoas diferentes.
Mas vamos conferir o que
está acontecendo.
61% de vocês acham que é
moralmente permitido
desviar o trem para o outro homem.
E 32% acham que é
moralmente proibido para ele
desviar o trem para o outro homem.
Agora, curiosamente, Judy Thomson espera
que mais gente se enquadre
nesta categoria.
É uma questão interessante
pensar nisso como uma aula,
porque ela tem a impressão de que
é bastante surpreendente
que esta seja a resposta
dada por vocês.
Mas, em todo caso, vamos passar
para um 2º caso de contraste
e ver como isto segue.
OK. Vamos supor agora que temos
apenas um caso de 2 vias.
No caso de 2 vias, a testemunha
Jim tem apenas 2 opções.
Ou o trem vai atingir 5 ou
ele pode desviar
o trem de tal forma que bata nele.
Eu quero voltar um segundo para pegar
os números do último slide,
porque eu esqueci de
gravá-los... acabei
ignorando-os.
Portanto, deixa eu
gravá-los... 6%, 61%, 32%.
OK. Então, seguindo para o novo caso.
É um trem de 2 vias e a
questão é esta:
Nas 2 opções da testemunha,
é moralmente obrigatório para
ele deixar o trem atingir 5
em vez dele mesmo, é moralmente
permitido para ele deixar
o trem atingir 5 em vez dele mesmo ou
é moralmente proibido para ele
deixar o trem atingir 5 em
vez de a ele mesmo?
OK? Então, vamos pensar neste caso.
Lembrem-se, é um caso de 2 vias.
O trem está indo em
direção a 5 pessoas.
E a pergunta é:
é obrigatório, permitido ou proibido
para ele desviar o trem de 5
para bater nele mesmo?
OK. E vamos ver os
números que saem aqui.
Temos cerca de 10 segundos
para descobrir se, aqui,
a distribuição será
semelhante ou diferente.
OK, portanto aqui os números
são: 8%, 70%, 22%.
Agora, o caso com o qual
queremos contrastar
é caso da Testemunha Clássica.
No caso da testemunha clássica,
a maior parte achava que ele
estava moralmente obrigado
a desviar o trem do que
neste caso particular.
No caso da testemunha
clássica, curiosamente,
vocês tiveram mais ou
menos a mesma opinião
sobre se isso era moralmente permitido.
E a maior parte acha que está
moralmente proibido para ele deixar
o trem atingir 5 em vez de si próprio.
A diferença interessante é esta aqui.
Vocês tomaram uma atitude diferente em
relação a se está moralmente
obrigatório para ele desviar o
trem quando a pessoa atingida
é ele próprio e quando a
pessoa atingida é outra.
Então, vamos voltar e realizar um
caso da testemunha clássica
para ver se, após analisar este caso,
existe uma mudança nas
intuições de vocês.
Portanto, este é o caso padrão da
testemunha que vocês já viram antes.
No caso da testemunha
clássica de 2 vias,
vocês acham que é moralmente
obrigatório, moralmente permitido
ou moralmente proibido para
Jim desviar o trem?
Vamos em 3, 2, 1...
E vamos ver os números que saem.
20%, 65%, 15%.
Então, após ter pensado sobre o
análogo em 1ª pessoa,
alguns de vocês –- embora muito menos
do que eu poderia imaginar –
mudaram de opinião.
Ao passo que, originalmente, 15% acharam
que era moralmente
obrigatório desviar o
trem...
oh, vocês mudaram de opinião
exatamente na direção contra a
que eu tinha previsto.
Estamos diante de um mistério.
Aqui está um pouco de
filosofia experimental
realizada em nossa sala de aula.
O que a Judy Thomson previu...
e podemos comentar nas seções por
que isso não ocorreu...
o que a Judy previu é que vocês
reagiriam da seguinte forma:
Se não é moralmente
mandatório para mim
desviar o trem na minha direção,
então não é moralmente
permitido para mim
desviar o trem na direção
de outra pessoa.
Se eu não estou disposto a ser
atingido, nesse caso,
eu não deveria estar decidindo
em nome de outra pessoa
que seja ela a atingida.
Então, eu quero que vocês pensem
sobre isso com o raciocínio
de Thomson, o que fez com que ela
visse como tão óbvio
o resultado a ponto de, ao
considerar o caso na 1ª pessoa,
as pessoas estariam inclinadas a
repensar o caso na 3ª pessoa.
E eu tenho de dizer que, na
leitura do artigo de 2008,
eu fui facilmente trazida para a
mentalidade descrita por ela.
Portanto, eu acho
surpreendente e interessante
ver que isso não foi o
que ocorreu aqui.
Vamos supor, no entanto, que, pelo
menos para alguns de vocês,
a intuição que você
teve como resultado
de considerar este caso foi algo
como a intuição de Thomson.
Assim que, enquanto na antiga
opinião no caso da testemunha
você pensou que a coisa
certa era matar 1
em vez de deixar 5 morrerem – ou
seja, no caso padrão da alavanca,
e isso é, de fato, o que a
maioria de vocês acha –,
no caso da testemunha padrão,
a maioria de vocês acha que a coisa
certa a se fazer é matar 1
em vez de deixar 5 morrerem.
Thomson diz que pensando no
caso na 1ª pessoa
você deve perceber que a testemunha
é muito mais como o homem gordo do
que você pensava inicialmente.
Na medida em que vocês rejeitam
a intuição de Thomson,
vocês estão em posição
de discordar dela.
Vamos passar para a visão
com a qual eu aposto que a maioria de
vocês vai acabar concordando,
uma vez que ela é exatamente
a oposta de Thomson;
o argumento de Greene
de que a assimilação deve
ir para outro lado.
Então, só para lembrá-los de
onde estamos na imagem,
o quebra-cabeça em que
começamos é que as pessoas
estavam dando uma resposta diferente
na testemunha e no homem gordo,
e Thomson tentou resolver o problema,
fazendo vocês verem a testemunha
no homem gordo.
Eu fui incapaz de, a partir
dos casos de Thomson,
mudar as intuições de vocês.
Portanto, estamos presos com
uma diferença residual
entre as suas respostas.
A maioria de vocês acha que está bem
desviar o trem na testemunha,
não fazendo o mesmo em si próprio,
mas que não está bem empurrar o
homem na ponte no homem gordo.
Greene vai nos dar uma 2ª
maneira de pensar
sobre como é que podemos chegar a
essas respostas juntos.
E o argumento dele é o seguinte:
Em geral, nós não estamos
numa posição muito boa
para determinar o que realmente
fundamenta o nosso raciocínio.
Há toda uma tradição na
psicologia social
que eu falei numa das aulas iniciais
que tem como objetivo mostrar que
muito do envolvimento das pessoas
ao tomarem decisões é
racionalização post-facto
de respostas intuitivas que
elas tinham não seguiam,
na verdade, o que elas apontariam
como as características
relevantes da situação.
As pessoas estão mais
propensas a escolher um objeto
que se encontra no lado
esquerdo de uma matriz visual
que um objeto que se
encontra no lado direito.
Mas, ao fazer a escolha,
elas não fornecem como razão a
localização do objeto;
elas fornecem como razão
alguma outra característica do objeto.
E quando olhamos para os resultados da
confabulação, na 2ª aula,
em que os indivíduos que se tinham
submetido a uma comissurotomia
– ou seja, cujo corpo
caloso foi cortado –,
para que os hemisférios direito e
esquerdo de seus cérebros
não estivessem
comunicados, descobrimos
que,
quando eles realizaram um ato baseado
na estimulação do cérebro direito,
o lado esquerdo do cérebro,
que é a parte linguística,
surgiu com uma explicação para
o que estavam fazendo,
que não era, obviamente, a verdadeira
fonte de seu comportamento.
Portanto, há muitos
casos, destaca Greene,
em que as nossas
motivações nos turvam.
Onde pensamos que estamos
respondendo a uma coisa,
mas na verdade estamos
respondendo à outra.
Um desses casos, diz Greene,
é a diferença em nossa resposta
para os casos do homem gordo
e da testemunha.
Então o que ocorre no
caso da testemunha
– onde nós estamos tentando
decidir se desviar o trem
de 5 para 1 –
é que o nosso sistema de
processamento racional é ativado.
Enquanto o que ocorre...
nós vamos dar algumas
provas em 1 minuto...
o que ocorre no caso do homem gordo
é que o nosso sistema de
processamento emocional é ativado.
E diz Greene: dada a escolha
entre o nosso sistema racional e o
nosso sistema emocional,
o sistema racional é aquele cujas
"vazões" devemos confiar.
Portanto, Greene afirma que a coisa
moralmente certa a se fazer
é empurrar o homem gordo.
Observem que este é um
argumento de várias etapas,
algumas cujas premissas são bem
mais controversas que outras.
A premissa de que as nossas
motivações são, por vezes,
turvas para nós é completamente
indiscutível por todos.
Não há dúvida de que muitas
vezes não temos conhecimento
do que nos leva a responder de
uma determinada forma.
Eu posso estar irritada porque os
meus pés estão molhados
e desconhecer o fato de que o motivo
que eu estou respondendo a você
de um jeito mal-humorado
não é porque você é irritante,
mas porque os meus pés
estão desconfortáveis.
Esse fenômeno é inegável.
Tentar saber a explicação real
para as nossas respostas
diferentes nestes 2 casos é uma
questão empírica interessante.
E durante a última década
foram coletados alguns dados de
neuroimagem muito interessantes
que sugerem que existem diferenças
sistemáticas de ativação
quando as pessoas dão respostas
utilitárias aos casos
e quando elas dão respostas
que parecem envolver tipos de noções
recorridas pelos deontologistas.
Noções como os direitos.
E há uma certa quantidade de
evidências adicionais
proveniente de outras pesquisas
que as áreas que são
diferencialmente ativadas nesses 2
casos
correspondem, por um lado,
com o que muitas vezes é considerado
como um sistema de
processamento racional
– um sistema de
processamento calculista –
e, por outro,
com as áreas do cérebro
que são implicadas
em casos independentes no
processamento emocional.
Portanto, a 1ª premissa
é incontroversa.
A 2ª premissa é
razoavelmente bem suportada.
Há controvérsias sobre os dados,
mas há evidências científicas de que
se trata de um bom argumento
que mostra basicamente o que
está escrito aqui.
A questão controversa é,
sendo as 2 primeiras
premissas são verdadeiras,
a 3ª premissa normativa é verdadeira?
Se as nossas respostas
para o homem gordo
são desencadeadas pela emoção,
enquanto que as nossas
respostas para a testemunha
são acionadas pelo sistema racional,
é o caso de que devemos
seguir o sistema racional?
Essa é uma afirmação
normativa, não empírica.
E mesmo se os argumentos que vamos
considerar daqui a pouco
estabelecem com sucesso a
verdade da 2ª premissa,
nós ainda não temos estabelecida a
verdade sobre a 3ª premissa.
Portanto, vamos falar sobre a evidência
que Greene encontrou a favor
da 2ª premissa –
de que o que se passa nos casos
como o do homem gordo
é uma resposta emocional,
ao passo que nos casos como o
da testemunha clássica
é uma resposta racional.
Greene aproveitou a última década
para colocar as pessoas em máquinas
de ressonância magnética,
em scanners que rastreiam onde o
sangue está fluindo no cérebro,
e apresentou a elas 3 tipos de dilemas.
O 1º tipo de dilema
é o que ele chama de
dilema pessoal/moral.
São os dilemas como o do homem gordo,
onde você está sendo questionado
se quer empurrar o sujeito da ponte.
Dilemas como o do caso médico,
apresentado por mim,
onde estamos considerando
a possibilidade de cortar um
paciente saudável
para salvar a vida dos outros.
Dilemas como o caso do bote salva-vidas,
em que não há comida e
água suficientes
e você considera a possibilidade
de se desfazer de 1 das pessoas a bordo,
de modo a deixar comida e água
suficientes para os outros sobreviventes.
Então essa é a 1ª categoria de casos
que ele propôs às pessoas no scanner.
A 2ª categoria de casos
testada no scanner
é a que ele chama de casos
morais e impessoais.
São casos como o da
testemunha com a alavanca,
onde você está diante de
um dilema moral,
mas não de um em que você pense,
de um modo mais próximo e pessoal,
em causar um dano específico
para um determinado indivíduo
que está por perto.
Casos como os que você
encontrou uma carteira
e tem de decidir devolvê-la ou não.
Casos em que você vota numa política
que tem certos tipos de
efeitos sobre as pessoas,
mas cujos efeitos são
relativamente alheios a você.
E, finalmente,
ele apresenta às pessoas o que ele
chama de dilemas não-morais.
Perguntas como: se estou tentando
ir de Cleveland a Chicago,
devo pegar ônibus, trem ou avião?
Ou se estou tentando decidir qual
desconto usar na internet
para economizar no transporte, eu
deveria fazer isso ou aquilo?
Casos que envolvem os mesmos
tipos de objetos, certo?
Homem gordo envolve trens.
Ônibus ou trem envolve trens.
Podemos ter um caso do desconto em
que você compra um barco.
Bote salva-vidas envolve barco.
Portanto, ele tem as pessoas no scanner
e apresenta esses tipos de
casos para elas.
E vocês vão perceber que
eu coloquei aqui
um pequeno quadro com código de
cores: preto, cinza e branco.
O que Greene descobriu no
artigo de 2001...
e alguns dados foram reanalisados e,
portanto, alguns detalhes
não foram mantidos,
mas muitos sim...
O que ele descobriu é que, se alguém
acredita, como muitos acreditam,
que as áreas do cérebro relacionadas
aqui – áreas do cérebro
como o giro frontal medial, giro
angular, giro cingulado posterior –,
se alguém acredita que essas são
áreas associadas com a emoção,
então temos boas evidências de que
nos casos pessoais/morais
as áreas do cérebro associadas com
a emoção são ativadas.
Ao passo que nos casos
impessoais/morais e não-morais
isso não ocorre.
Por outro lado, parece que
um monte de áreas
que são tradicionalmente associadas
com a memória de trabalho
– lobo parietal, giro
frontal médio –
são mais ativas no caso impessoal
e no caso não-moral que
no caso pessoal.
E aqui está a famosa imagem
do texto de Greene
reproduzida em diversos artigos,
que mostra as áreas do
cérebro que exibem
uma resposta diferencial nos
casos pessoais/morais
em contraste com os outros casos.
Portanto, parece que existe alguma
evidência, talvez decisiva,
a favor da 2ª premissa.
A favor da premissa de que o que
ocorre nos casos pessoais/morais
é uma ativação da parte do
cérebro associada com a emoção;
e o que ocorre em casos
como o da testemunha
é uma ativação da parte do
cérebro associada ao raciocínio
e outros tipos de processos
mais controlados.
Além disso, diz Greene,
há muitas evidências
comportamentais que suportam a
hipótese
de que uma das coisas que
ocorre quando respondemos
a dilemas morais hipotéticos é que
rastreamos características
do caso que não são
moralmente relevantes.
Por exemplo, há um estudo do
início da década de 2000,
dos economistas comportamentais
Small e Loewenstein,
que aponta que num sentido muito
profundo as vítimas identificáveis
produzem em nós respostas
emocionais mais fortes
que as vítimas não-identificáveis.
E isso não é apenas a diferença
entre a foto da criança
para quem são destinadas
as suas doações
versus a descrição da criança para
quem vão as suas doações.
Há, de fato, uma
diferença impressionante
na disposição das pessoas entre
dar uma gratificação
de um jogo no laboratório
para pessoa nº 4...
certo, elas tiram um nome de um
chapéu que diz pessoa nº 4...
e os casos em que elas
podem decidir quanto dinheiro
querem dar para a pessoa
cujo número estão prestes
a tirar do chapéu.
Em nenhuma dessas condições
eles sabem quem será a pessoa nº 4.
Mas o fato é que, no 1º caso,
eles tiram a pessoa nº 4 do
chapéu e pensam:
"Ah, eu vou dar esta quantia de
dinheiro para esta pessoa".
Ao passo que, no 2º caso,
elas decidem a quantia que
querem dar para a pessoa
cujo número elas estão
prestes a tirar.
O fato de que isso produz respostas
consistentemente diferentes
nos indivíduos sugere a Greene e,
talvez, a muitos de vocês,
que usar as nossas intuições
sobre esses tipos de casos
para construir as nossas teorias morais
pode não ser a melhor maneira de
proceder, uma vez que, presumivelmente,
são poucos os que pensam que há uma
diferença moral relevante
entre se você sabe o número da
pessoa a quem você vai gratificar
ou se você está prestes a
descobrir o número da pessoa
a quem você vai gratificar.
Aqui está outra coisa que parece afetar
as nossas respostas morais aos casos.
Este é um trabalho feito por Jon Haidt,
autor de The Happiness
Hypothesis, e colaboradores.
Caso você esteja decidindo que
punição aplicar em alguém
– decidindo o quão
errado foi um ato –,
se você for induzido a sentir nojo,
seja por se sentar a uma mesa suja
ou por ter sido treinado para
associar determinados termos
com nojo a partir de uma
sugestão hipnótica,
você será mais duro na
hora da punição.
Eu entendo que a maioria de
vocês não acha
que as pessoas mereçam
punição mais severa
quando você estiver sentindo nojo
porque a mesa à sua frente está suja.
Eu assumo que vocês saibam
o quão ruim é um ato
independentemente dos
sentimentos de nojo...
Mas parece que uma das coisas que
acompanha a condenação
é esse sentimento.
Em 1 minuto eu vou comentar
sobre como isso se conecta
com a discussão mais geral de
Sunstein sobre heurísticas.
Finalmente, alguns trabalhos de
David Pizarro, um PhD de Yale,
sugerem que, nos casos
específicos do Trolley,
podemos mexer com as
intuições das pessoas
– em casos como o do homem gordo –
apenas ao variar o que a
maioria diria que são
características moralmente
irrelevantes da situação.
Pizarro apresenta aos indivíduos
2 versões diferentes do
caso do homem gordo.
Na 1ª, você é perguntado se
é moralmente permitido,
obrigatório ou proibido
empurrar um homem chamado
Tyrone Peyton da ponte,
a fim de salvar 100 membros da
Filarmônica de Nova York.
E na 2ª você é questionado se
é moralmente aceitável
empurrar um homem chamado Chip
Ellsworth III da ponte
para salvar 100 membros da
Orquestra de Jazz do Harlem.
Portanto, a questão é se empurrar
um homem branco da ponte
para salvar 100 pessoas de
ascendência africana
ou empurrar um homem negro da ponte
para salvar 100 pessoas de
ascendência europeia
deve produzir respostas diferentes.
E, curiosamente – talvez como resultado de
um certo tipo de autocorreção –,
os liberais dizem que é menos
moralmente aceitável
empurrar Tyrone Peyton da ponte que
empurrar o Chip Ellsworth.
Independentemente da
direção dos números,
o interessante é os
números serem diferentes;
seguindo uma característica que
a maioria de nós acha
que não é uma característica
moralmente relevante.
Portanto, isso parece fortalecer a
2ª premissa de Greene...
um argumento que ele traça
em mais detalhes
num artigo que leremos
trechos após a pausa,
chamado The Secret Joke
of Kant's Soul...
parece que existem boas
razões para pensar
que pelo menos algumas das nossas
respostas a esses casos
estão seguindo características que não
endossaríamos reflexivamente.
E Greene pensa em especial
no homem gordo,
nossa relutância em empurrar o homem
gordo da ponte é o seguimento
de uma dessas características
moralmente irrelevantes.
Os julgamentos
deontológicos, diz
Greene
– aqueles em que estamos relutantes em
executar a ação utilitarista –,
são movidos por respostas emocionais.
Os julgamentos consequencialistas
são movidos pelas cognitivas.
E as respostas deontológicas, diz ele,
carecem de significado moral.
Na verdade, a própria deontologia é uma
espécie de confabulação moral.
Eu vou dar a Kant a última
palavra desta aula.
Portanto, aqueles que estão com
saudades do sábio de Konigsberg,
saibam que ele vai ter a última
palavra na aula de hoje,
ao lado de uma bela imagem do seu rosto.
Mas antes eu quero usar os
últimos 10 minutos da aula
para analisar o 3º artigo que
tínhamos considerado para hoje,
ou seja, o artigo de Cass Sunstein.
Sunstein, seguindo a mesma
linha de Greene,
embora recorrendo a uma
literatura um pouco diferente,
argumenta que uma boa parte do
nosso raciocínio moral
opera exatamente da mesma forma que
o nosso raciocínio normal,
isto é, fazendo uso das heurísticas,
que conhecemos na aula
sobre duplo processamento.
As heurísticas são uma
ferramenta rápida e sóbria
para lidar com a complexidade do
mundo quando somos confrontados
com tarefas de tomada de
decisões sensíveis ao tempo.
E o modo que as heurísticas
trabalham é muito inteligente.
Elas trabalham a partir de algo chamado
substituição de atributos.
Estamos interessados ??num atributo-alvo
– algo que é relativamente difícil
de descobrir sobre o mundo.
E, em vez disso, concentramos a nossa
atenção num atributo heurístico
– algo que é relativamente fácil
de descobrir sobre o mundo.
Portanto, alguns de vocês podem
utilizar isso quando estão tentando
distinguir o seu celular do
celular de outras pessoas.
O atributo-alvo, a coisa que você
realmente está interessado...
este é o meu celular?
Algo que você só será
capaz de determinar
ligando o telefone e conferindo
se os contatos existentes
são os contatos adicionados
por você, digamos.
Mas você pode tornar a sua vida mais
fácil, colocando uma capa
ou um adesivo no celular ou
alguma característica
que faça com que você encontre o seu
telefone melhor e mais rápido.
Certo? Portanto, você faz uso de
uma facilidade para encontrar
o atributo em vez de uma dificuldade
para determinar o atributo.
Em geral, esta é uma forma
extraordinária de navegar pelo mundo.
Os atributos-alvo e heurísticos
geralmente coincidem.
É assim que os atributos heurísticos
se tornam aqueles que você usa
como os marcadores do alvo.
E toma muito menos esforço processar as
características da superfície
do mundo que gastar tempo
trabalhando com os detalhes
de cada uma das coisas que
você quer dar sentido.
Então eu me vi esta manhã fazendo
uso de um atributo heurístico
no meu trajeto até a universidade.
Eu estava parada no semáforo e
notei com o canto do olho
que o carro ao meu lado
começava a se mover.
Agora, claro, o atributo que
eu estava interessada
em saber era se a luz
tinha ficado verde.
Mas porque eu não conseguia ver a luz
verde desde onde eu estava,
eu fui capaz de usar o
movimento do carro ao meu lado
como um indicador da coisa que
eu estava preocupada.
No entanto, a heurística poderia
ter falhado neste caso.
Poderia ser que o carro
estivesse em movimento
mesmo que a luz ainda
estivesse vermelha.
Poderia ser que o carro
estivesse em movimento
no acostamento e tivesse
uma luz especial.
Mas na maior parte, usamos a heurística
o tempo todo e ela nos ajuda.
O argumento de Sunstein é que
nos casos não-morais
as pessoas normalmente
usam a heurística.
Que, embora seja útil, também
pode induzir a erros.
E que, nos casos morais,
as pessoas também costumam
usar as heurísticas.
Mas assim como ela pode induzir a
erros nos casos não-morais,
também pode induzir a erros
nos casos morais.
E, em particular, ele pensa
que ela faz isso
numa série de casos
postos em discussão.
Por exemplo... e eu pressinto que
estamos a ponto de terminar...
eu disse que Kant teria a
última palavra,
mas Kant vai ter a última
palavra na quinta-feira.
Nós vamos analisar Sunstein
e um dos exemplos...
e então chegaremos a Kant.
Sunstein aponta, por exemplo,
que há uma heurística
chamada a heurística de
disponibilidade.
É uma heurística que diz: eu
estou tentando descobrir
qual a probabilidade de que algo
esteja prestes a ocorrer
e aqui está uma boa maneira
de determinar isso.
Eu penso como é fácil para mim refletir
sobre casos que já ocorreram.
Assim, sempre que me preocupa que os
meus filhos sejam sequestrados,
eu penso comigo: quantos
amigos que eu conheço
tiveram os filhos sequestrados?
Quantas pessoas que eu conheço
E quando eu descubro que a
resposta é zero, eu relaxo.
Esse tipo de heurística é
muitas vezes correta,
mas pode nos desviar do caminho.
Vamos supor que perguntem para
você se é mais provável
que haja mais palavras em
inglês que terminem em ING
ou mais palavras em inglês cuja
penúltima letra é N.
É muito mais fácil pensar em
palavras que terminam em ING
e as pessoas tendem a dizer
que há mais palavras
que terminam em ING que palavras
cuja penúltima letra é N.
Mas, claro, cada palavra
que termina em ING
é uma palavra cuja
penúltima letra é o N.
Você foi enganado pela
heurística de disponibilidade.
Ou vamos supor que você use
o que às vezes é chamada de
heurística de representatividade.
Que a probabilidade da
ocorrência de algo
acompanha o seu grau de tipicidade.
Isso também é algo
frequentemente correto.
Uma postura típica
é uma das posturas que ocorre
com mais frequência.
Porém, como vocês sabem da Linda,
no caso da caixa do banco,
ou do fazendeiro, no caso do trator,
se eu perguntar para vocês
se é mais provável que um
habitante aleatório de Iowa
seja um fazendeiro ou um
fazendeiro com um trator,
a heurística de representatividade
vai atraí-lo para dizer
que é mais provável que a pessoa seja
um fazendeiro com um trator.
Mas, obviamente,
cada fazendeiro com um trator
também é um fazendeiro.
Agora lembrem-se que os
argumentos de Sunstein para 1 e 2
são fáceis de fazer porque
temos uma forma independente
de determinar se alguém cometeu
um erro nesses casos.
Podemos ver o que deu errado na
heurística de disponibilidade
e na de representatividade
porque podemos ver que é,
de fato, mais provável
que penúltima letra de
uma palavra seja N
que as 3 últimas letras sejam ING.
Podemos ver que é mais provável que
alguém seja um fazendeiro
que alguém seja um
fazendeiro com um trator.
Porque em ambos os casos,
um deles é uma postura
especial do outro.
O argumento de Sunstein para
a heurística moral
vai percorrer mais etapas.
Para ele, não é suficiente
mostrar o que definimos
– que, nos casos morais, as pessoas
costumam usar as heurísticas –,
ele também vai mostrar que ao fazer
isso, elas estão cometendo erros.
Em que a questão sobre como podemos
obter um identificador independente
do que é cometer um erro é um
elemento complicado.
Mas primeiro vamos pensar no argumento
dele a favor da afirmação
de que, nos casos morais, as pessoas
costumam usar as heurísticas.
E eu vou concluir a aula de hoje com
2 exemplos dados por ele.
E, na quinta, começaremos a
percorrer alguns casos particulares
em que eu contarei com a
participação de vocês.
Portanto, um dos exemplos dados
por ele é, novamente,
um trabalho de Jonathan Haidt
sobre um fenômeno conhecido
como perplexidade moral.
Como vocês sabem ao ler o
artigo de Sunstein,
as pessoas costumam
responder à questão:
"É moralmente aceitável para
um irmão e uma irmã
se envolverem em relações incestuosas
consensuais e não prejudiciais?"
afirmando que isso é
moralmente inaceitável.
Mas quando se pede para
fornecer razões para isso,
os indivíduos têm
dificuldade em fazê-lo.
Da mesma forma, muita gente
está inclinada a pensar
que há algo moralmente problemático
em limpar o chão do banheiro
com a bandeira do país ou comer o seu
cachorro que foi atropelado
por um carro, mas há uma dificuldade
em articular o porquê disso.
Sunstein sugere que a razão é uma
"sobre-extensão" da heurística.
Da mesma forma, ele ressalta que em
casos de enquadramento moral
– e vamos abordar isso na
próxima aula –,
casos como o da doença asiática
que eu apresentei a vocês...
se você apresentar um dilema moral
como algo que envolve vidas salvas
ou vidas perdidas – mesmo
que sejam apenas descrições
complementares do mesmo resultado –,
as pessoas são susceptíveis a
dar respostas diferentes.
E Sunstein conclui com base nisso
que as pessoas fazem uso
das heurísticas
no raciocínio moral tal como no
raciocínio não-moral.
E, na quinta, vamos começar com
a discussão de Sunstein
sobre esses casos e, depois,
vamos deixar que Kant e Mill
tenham as últimas palavras
no debate do Trolley.
Vejo vocês em breve.